you have to stop trusting these apps  everything can be toxic even water look  up water toxicity if you drink 15 cups  really quickly you get really sick these  apps don't base their toxic ratings on  studies where people are getting sick  from hair care products they're based on  unrealistic conditions like rats eating  massive amounts these studies are  purposely trying to find the line where  it becomes toxic so scientists can work  out how to make sure it is safe if  you're buying from a reputable brand  they're using the ingredient in a  scientifically supported safe way these  apps are misinterpreting the science  they're basically saying drinking 15  cups of water is really toxic so you  need to avoid anything with even one  drop of water